now tomorrow is the end of an era it's
the eve of new beginnings now just after
the ball drops in times square tomorrow
night a new day begins now we're not
talking about new year's we're talking
about the end of bill de blasio as mayor
of new york city so undoubtedly the
worst mirror in american history so
tonight we say goodbye to bill de blasio
now bill de blasio was born warren
wilhelm jr and he did what no other
mayor dream possible in just a few short
years he has completely ruined new york
city by almost every measure he has been
a complete and utter disaster
so since bill de blasio took over
murders in new york city have spiked by
nearly 50 percent
rapes are up by 26 percent
according to a report by busby which
looked at data from the american housing
survey along with other federal data new
york city is by far the dirtiest city in
the country
new york uh a city also had more than
two million homes with pest infestations
which include rats roaches and mice
a state audit confirmed the filth with
most uh inspected city blocks and
sidewalks found to be dirty so it's
confirmed so under bill de blasio new
york city transit is disgusting too
according to internal mass transit
authority documents released earlier
this year
subway cars have been soiled with blood
vomit urine and feces
in june of this year for example there
were over 130 incidents of soiled train
cars that included 27 trains covered in
poop
26 covered in vomit and 21 in urine when
bill de blasio hilariously tried to run
for president this show was one of the
first to challenge him on that
the city is dirty and it's getting
dirtier one of my producers told me just
yesterday that he was in a crowded
subway car and a man dropped his
trousers and defecated in the middle of
the car and no one did anything about it
and that's a metaphor for what's
happening i go there regularly and i
have my whole life and every time i go
under your mayorship it is dirtier
there's filth on the sidewalks do you
notice any of that you weakened the
sanction against public urination
this city smells like urine do you
notice that tucker is just not true i go
all over new york city all the time i'm
sorry i've been here for decades and
decades this city is more orderly and
cleaner and safer than it's been for
many many years we've got more to do and
we're going to keep making it better
so bill de blasio hasn't done anything
to fix the filth he doesn't even seem
interested instead he's too busy erasing
history bill de blasio supported the
removal of the teddy roosevelt statue
outside new york city's american museum
of natural history which is a museum
roosevelt's family helped found
in his last few months in office he
helped remove a statue of thomas
jefferson from the city hall where it
stood for the last
187 years
it's no wonder that hundreds of
thousands of new yorkers have fled the
city and that was even before covet the
city's population dropped by over two
hundred 000 from 2017 to 2018 which at
the time was the largest drop since the
70s
over 300 000 have fled between march and
october of this year alone
former president trump he summed it up
best bill de blasio is a joke
mayor bill de blasio taking questions
for the first time as a presidential
candidate already trading jabs with
donald trump de blasio responding to the
president who made his feelings known on
twitter calling de blasio the worst
mayor in the u.s adding he is a joke but
if you like high taxes and crime he's
your man nyc hates him and as for the
voters who know him best right here in
new york city a recent quinnipiac poll
shows 76 percent of them say he
shouldn't run
so doing his failed run for president de
blasio cost taxpayers 320 thousand
dollars by using the nypd as security
detail now he still hasn't paid that
back and his office hasn't said if he
ever will
that's in addition to the 850 million
taxpayer dollars de blasio's wife
supposedly lost track of while
overseeing her thrive nyc mental health
scheme so these are just a few of the
reasons why
we'll be happy to see bill de blasio
leave but before we celebrate the end of
bill de blasio we would be remiss if we
didn't look back at some of his greatest
hits now we're going to start with the
rough beginning when his clumsiness
killed chuck the groundhog
this footage from groundhog day 2014
shows freshly inaugurated mayor bill de
blasio appearing to drop staten island
chuck a week after the de blasio fumble
the groundhog did a few more events
before being found in zeus space
deceased on february 9th
so bill de blasio's sloppiness didn't
end there
then there was the time he tweeted and
then deleted a picture of himself
staring at a woman's chest now we're not
kidding his line of sight was so clearly
visible in the reflection of his
sunglasses i mean
or how could we forget when he sounded
like a chipmunk at a campaign rally
we're doing something that should've
been done a long time ago in this
country we're passing legislation this
year
to guarantee working people like every
other industrialized country in the
world to guarantee working people by law
two weeks pay vacation every year
all right then this year the clumsy and
dumb mayor of new york city the slob
um
stuffed his face with french fries to
try to bribe new yorkers to get
vaccinated
do you say
free fries when you get vaccinated
um
i got vaccinated
you're saying i can get this
a delicious rice
just think of this when you think of
vaccination
oxen
oxidation
if only de blasio cared enough about
cleaning up new york as he did about
putting the jab in your arm well
farewell bill de blasio you won't be
missed hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else